here we go so we've got sine and cosine
this is from naught to two pi
okay now i said we what we're interested
in is the enclosed area
the enclosed area from north should put
that in
to two pi okay so you can see it's
unambiguously
this area in here and if you haven't
gotten used to it already
um do you get some colors they're so
useful
um circle geometry tree graphs that kind
of thing any time when you've got lots
of lines and different kinds of things
you want to distinguish between
so that's the area i'm interested in
right now it is an area between two
curves okay
so if i want to form the integral that's
going to give me this area
right i would say area is equal to
now the first thing i'm going to need is
some boundaries
right because i want an area so it's
going to be a definite integral so how
do i find the boundaries
i'm going to solve for the intersection
of these two graphs right
so let's just do that very quickly sine
x equals cos x that's where
the two graphs intersect right sine x
equals cos x okay so
you can divide both sides give you 10 x
is equal to one
off which you should be able to give me
the two values what are the two values
okay so first one pi over four we know
that one
pretty well okay and because tan is
periodic
your next answer of course will be five
pi over four because you've got to go
forward
pi radians that's the that's the period
okay so therefore pi on four
those are our boundaries good so i'm
going to slap that onto my definition
now seeing as it's a area between two
curves right
rather than work out two separate areas
i can sorry two separate integrals i can
whack them into one how will i do it
i want to think about the one that's on
top right which in this case is side
okay and then i can subtract the area
underneath now
be careful there's an area underneath
the curve here right sorry underneath
the axis what difference does that make
to the integral that we form
i don't forget i'm doing an area between
two curves
right so had i just calculated
for instance um this area
these two boundaries and just inside or
adjusted cars
right their parts of those would be
negative but because i'm doing the
subtraction
right i mean remember we gave this
illustration
if i took the whole thing and i just
moved it up right instead of taking
sine x and cos
x you know if we did some kind of
vertical shift that
took the axis out of the question right
um sine x plus five and cos x plus five
if i form this integral right side x
plus five
cos x plus five right you'd get exactly
the same integral
right so in fact even though part of it
is under the axis it doesn't matter
okay it doesn't matter precisely because
it's area between
two curves all right great so that's
that
with respect to x all right
you can walk me through this what should
i write
square bracket negative cos x good
this is negative cos axis and actually
go to negative sign
x like so okay and evaluate out the
boundaries
okay
it's not a minus sign on the front there
okay now can we do this how how well can
we do it in our heads do you think
a five pound four one minus
okay cos of five pi over four
plus sine of five pi on
four who reckons they could do their
exact value think about it
so that's going to be sorry this is
negative 1 over root 2. because your
base angle is
uh pi and 4 right so it's one over two
but thinking about the quadrant here
what about sine pi pi 4
i'm not getting much consensus think
about it
negative plus negative plus
which quadrant are we in think about it
in
you're in the third quadrant right so
that's why they're both negative okay
great that's that now i haven't done
this other side over here
that's just pi on four plus
so therefore these are easy too right
yeah you could you could go there
couldn't you right but i'll do both
okay there you go and we can simplify
from there okay just for the sake of it
let's see negative this will be negative
2 on root 2 which is just negative root
2 and this will be the same
so you're going to get two roo two
now that's the integral okay and the
integral doesn't have units on it
i would conclude therefore the area is
and i'd slap the units on there
sweat okay fantastic good